con un discurso que reivindica su
trabajo andrés manuel lópez obrador
celebró sus dos años al frente de la
presidencia mexicana un periodo en el
que el mandatario considera que ha
cumplido la mayoría de sus promesas de
100 compromisos presentados hace dos
años en el zócalo hemos cumplido 97
solo están pendientes o en proceso 3
descentralizar el gobierno federal
impulsar el desarrollo de fuentes de
energías renovables mediante la
rehabilitación de las hidroeléctricas y
conocer la verdad acerca de la
desaparición de los jóvenes de
ayotzinapa entre sus palabras no ha
habido mucho espacio para la mayor
crisis que enfrenta hasta el coronavirus
lópez obrador ha lamentado las más de
100 mil víctimas a causa de la pandemia
pero ha reivindicado sus estrategias no
convencionales que según él han salvado
miles de vidas decidimos enfrentar
la crisis sanitaria como la económica
con entrega eficacia y con estrategias
no convencionales que nos han permitido
ir saliendo poco a poco de la adversidad
en lo que respecta a la seguridad
destacó la disminución del crimen aunque
los datos reflejan subidas en homicidios
y feminicidios que han hecho de este
2020 el año más violento de la historia
reciente también habló de su otro gran
problema la crisis económica pero lo
hizo de forma positiva a pesar de los
datos que reflejan una caída del 9,6 por
ciento del pib en su segundo año y del
desempleo que se está cumpliendo el
pronóstico que hicimos en el sentido de
que la crisis tendría un comportamiento
en forma de v
queríamos hasta el fondo como ocurrió en
abril te saldríamos del hoyo como de
hecho ha venido sucediendo como vive un
tercio de su mandato y a pesar de las
crisis abiertas que tiene su gobierno
lópez obrador cuenta con un apoyo del 60
por ciento de la población